this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
apple is going on an all-out spree with
their new m1 chip
which is now in five of their devices
four macs including the new 24 inch imac
as well as in the new ipad pro which is
just
incredible seeing as it's super thin and
light and honestly
we can't blame apple for reusing the m1
so much
because they've absolutely knocked it
out of the park with
this new chip and it's quickly gaining
popularity
because it is truly game changing
offering incredible amounts of
performance while also getting amazing
battery life and i personally believe
that people who buy an
m1 mac or ipad pro right now are gonna
have
a very reliable computer for many many
years
but one huge question remains now that
there are five
m1 machines how in the world are you
supposed to choose between them
well that's what we're going to answer
in this video
and i'm confident that if you stick
through to the end you'll know for sure
which one you should buy so let's get
right into it the first m1 mac i want to
start with is actually the worst value
right now
in my opinion and that's the m1 macbook
pro
this was one of the first m1 max to get
released back in november
with a starting price of thirteen
hundred dollars
and after doing a ton of testing with it
we realized that it wasn't really worth
the extra 300
compared to the m1 macbook air first off
it wasn't really that much faster than
the air
even with the included fan that helps
keep the temps down
and we quickly realized that apple's m1
chip
is so efficient that the fan really
doesn't do much at all
on top of that we also tested the
speakers and realized that the ones on
the macbook air
actually sound a bit better than the
pros which is very surprising
and then in terms of the display quality
the pro used to stand out with its p3
wide color gamut support
but now apple added that to the air so
the only benefit
is that you have a brighter display on
the pro with 500 nits of brightness
compared to the air's 400 but it's not
that big of a deal then going even
further
the macbook pro has the touch bar on the
keyboard
which i personally don't like because
adjusting volume and brightness becomes
a bit more annoying and on top of that
there are leaks and rumors that the
redesigned macbook pro coming later this
year
is gonna ditch the touch bar for good so
if that ends up happening
it shows how apple truly feels about the
touch bar
and that's not good news for people who
are buying this model
and that's actually the biggest problem
for the m1 macbook pro
when the redesigned 14 inch model comes
out this year
potentially even being announced at wwdc
this 13 inch model is gonna sound like
old news
which is gonna hurt its resale value
that's exactly what happened to the
15-inch macbook pro
when the 16-inch came out the resale
value tanked so based on all of that
especially since you don't get that much
more value for the extra 300
compared to the air we would honestly
not recommend buying
the 13 inch macbook pro unless you think
you absolutely need the built-in fan
for some specific workflow or something
like that now moving on to the second m1
machine
i actually want to pivot over to the
ipad pro
because this one is in a totally unique
position but before we get into that i
want to give a huge shout out to the
sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is
seriously the best way to go you can
build a great looking website like we
did with literally no web making
experience
it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog e-commerce or
anything else you simply choose a
template customize blocks of text and
images and then
easily move them around it's incredibly
simple affordable
and ours have been running flawlessly
for now over three years
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required
by going to squarespace.com max tech or
use our custom link below when you're
ready to launch
to save 10 on your first purchase of a
website or domain
unlike every other m1 machine the ipad
pro is absolutely the most
portable and it's the only one that has
both touchscreen support
and apple pencil support which opens it
up to a huge market of people
who want to use those two features so
the ipad pro is definitely the one
that's the most comfortable to use on
the couch
or actually anywhere since it's the only
m1 machine
that comes with optional 5g cellular
networking
which is missing on the macbooks on top
of that you can get the magic keyboard
case
which basically turns it into a super
premium laptop replacement
with its iconic floating ipad design
which makes it totally unique and the
built-in charging port in the hinge that
allows you to use the all-new
thunderbolt port for connecting devices
or even a hub
with a bunch of different ports and
connectors however
there are definitely a couple of
problems with the ipad pro
the main one is that you're going to be
spending a ton of extra money
compared to one of the other m1 machines
for example
the magic keyboard case is going to run
you at least 300
if you want the 11 inch model the apple
pencil
is going to run you 125 if you buy it on
amazon
and if you want upgraded specs like more
storage
16 gigabytes of ram or 5g you're going
to be spending a ton of money
close to 2 000 or even more and then if
you choose the 12.9 inch model with the
new mini led display
you're spending an extra 300 on top of
the 11 inch model
so yeah it gets pricey very quickly
and that's the main problem with the
ipad pro yes you get the super fast m1
chip
but the ipad os software is currently
extremely
limited compared to mac os so you can't
even use all of the power yet but in my
personal opinion based on prior leaks
and rumors
apple is going to be announcing the
addition of pro apps like final cut
logic and xcode to the ipad pro at their
wwdc event in just a few weeks
and then that will finally make it worth
it now on the plus side i believe that
we have finally reached
peak ipad thanks to the m1 ship that is
pushing it to its thermal
limits so it's basically as future proof
as you're gonna get because i don't
believe
they're gonna be able to squeeze out
that much power within the next year or
two
so if you're thinking of having one m1
device that can do it all
high performance computing and touch
based features
i fully believe that if you invest your
cash into this ipad pro
right now it's going to be at least two
to four years
until apple is going to come out with a
really compelling ipad pro
that can even touch this model but i'd
say for overall bang for the buck
the m1 macbook air is by far the best
value
for a few different reasons so let's get
into that model first off a thousand
dollars is a killer price for the
performance you're getting
basically beating out every other
windows laptop out there
like the microsoft surface laptop 4 that
we just compared the macbook air to
even without a fan performance is great
and the best part is that you don't have
to worry about dust clogging up the
inside of the system over time
since there is no fan and heatsink to
rely on and compared to the ipad pro
you're getting the full featured mac os
that can take advantage of
every bit of the m1 ship right now on
top of that the m1 macbook air is gonna
hold its value the best
out of any of the m1 machines because
we're not expecting
a new redesigned model to come until
sometime next year
and i personally think that the new one
is gonna start at a price of
twelve hundred dollars and i think that
apple is going to continue selling
this same exact m1 model for a thousand
dollars
for the next couple of years which is
exactly what they did in the past
with their 2017 macbook air which helped
it hold its value
so based on all of that if you're
looking to get the best bang
for the buck m1 mac while having great
portability
the m1 macbook air is definitely the one
to get
and it's actually a hundred dollars off
brand new
right now on amazon which is an insane
deal
so we're gonna leave the link down in
the description below so you can check
it out
but wait we still have two more m1 mac
machines
that have their own advantages that can
absolutely
kill those other computers in very
specific ways
so let's get into the brand new 24 inch
imac
if you don't really care that much about
portability like let's say you're fine
with having a desktop setup
or you want an awesome and reliable
computer for your whole family to use
the imac actually gives you the best
bang for the buck
as a complete package for thirteen
hundred dollars
you're getting the awesome and reliable
m1 chip you're getting the very first
masterpiece of a redesigned apple
silicon mac with its
incredibly thin package and a design
that will complement
any home or office but by far the most
important feature that you can't get
with any of the other m1 max is the 24
inch
4.5 k display which is incredibly sharp
color accurate and bright this is going
to be awesome for productivity work
since it's much easier and more
convenient compared to using a small
13-inch display
like the other m1 max and multi-tasking
is also
easier for the same exact reason and if
you didn't already know
apple uses lg's displays for their imacs
and
lg's 24 inch 4k display
is priced at 700 alone
and it's not even 4.5 k like the imac
display is
so apple is packing a ton of value for
just 1300
with this new imac but it gets even
better because it's also got the best
speakers out of any mac
ever the best microphones out of any mac
ever
and the best 1080p webcam out of any
mac ever and on top of that you're
getting a super reliable
magic mouse and magic keyboard in the
box so if you add up everything that
you're getting
this is by far the best bang for the
buck m1 machine
if you're willing to have a desktop
setup instead of going portable
and since it literally just got
redesigned this imac is gonna hold its
value incredibly well
going into the future so that's a plus
now i know some of you are gonna argue
that the n1 mac mini is a better bang
for the buck
but i'd argue that you won't find a
display in peripherals
that match the quality of the imax
without spending more
than thirteen hundred dollars but there
are a couple of good reasons
to get the imac so let's finally finish
up with that model
the main advantage that you get with the
m1 mac mini is that it now comes
with a 10 gigabit ethernet port option
which is not available
on any of the other m1 macs but if you
don't really care about that
then it honestly doesn't really matter
i'd say the best reason to go for the
mac mini
is that you can get in the m1 chip door
for the absolute lowest price
being an amazing budget computer for the
average joe
or even those starting out doing
productivity work the main benefit is
that if you already have a keyboard
a mouse and a display you literally just
spend seven hundred dollars on the n1
mac mini
and that's it you've got an excellent
machine and to make it even better
amazon is currently selling it for only
669 dollars
which makes it an even better deal so
you'll find
those links down in the description
below but overall i would say that out
of
all of those m1 machines i would
personally buy the m1 macbook air
for only 900 on amazon because it's got
the added benefit of portability
for a low price which is gonna help it
hold its value
probably better than any of the other
macs and it's gonna be by far
the easiest one to resell in the future
thanks to its popularity
so hopefully this video helps you make a
decision and if it did go ahead and hit
that circle above to subscribe
because we're going to be doing in-depth
testing with some of the new imacs
very soon and definitely check the links
below for those great deals on amazon
definitely watch one of those two videos
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video